اخر عشريه مرت فيها تونس بازمات كبيره لا
ننسى ما نحكيش على التسعينات نحكي على
2001 احداث احداث احداث سبتمبر في نيويورك
وتلك العمليه اوقفت الطياره عن والسياحه
الى اخره وهو بقينا لمده والاقتصاد
التونسي يعاني لان احد اهم الموارد لذلك
الاقتصاد
يعني كانت تشغل حوالي نصف مليون بين
التشغيل المباشر وغير مباشر
والطيران مهم لان حتى في النقل والتنقل
الى اخره
وبعد سنه فقدت جاءت عمليه الارهابيه
الغريبه يعني الكنيسه اليهودي في جربه
الذي يحج
اليهود
السنويا في في اخر الربيع
كان اليهود من اصل تونسي ومن غير اصل
تونسي
على العالم ثم بعد ذلك جاءت في اواسطه
مساله تصوير البرايم والازمه العالميه
الاولى ثم الازمه الماليه التي انطلقت على
هذه الرساله سنه 2007 يعني
سعر البترول حتى ال125 دولار يعني
حادث سليمان ايضا لان عمليه ارهابيه
جاءتنا يعني من الخارج جاؤوا وتسلل
بس انا سالتك عن الرئيس يعني
في الايام الاخيره النتائج كل هذا جاءت
بالاحتجاجات وجاءت بمشاكل الاجتماعيه وهم
مشاكل تماس المواطن في شغل وفي كرامته وفي
كذا الى اخره وبالتالي همم رغم ان عده
اشياء همم
معناها
الفتح الانترنت
الوسائد همم الاجتماع
يعني كانت عده اشياء ولكن ضغطت على
الاقتصاد تونسي كان كبير ورغم ان في ذلك
الوقت تونس لم تضطر الى التدين الذي وصلته
اليوم تمام وكان هناك
لا يجري فيه همم
يعني فيه مخاطر ولكن ايضا كان واعيا بان
هنالك موزه خارجيه ست هز المنطق كان تيقن
في الايام الاخيره في اخر وقت بطبيعه همم
الحال لان كلنا بدانا نتيقا بان هنالك شيء
ما سيجري لكن لم نكن نتوقع ان تونس تكون
البدايه وهمم
ثم اليمن ثم النصر ثم ليبيا ثم ثم الى
اخره وكادت الامور تمتد الى بلدان اخرى
وهذا هو اليوم احنا نعيش نظام همم
بشكل جديد همم
في في وضع بالزيت جديد جديد
الامور في الانترنت
وما يجري في التوازنات الجديده القلوب